[音楽]
ブーブー
本当に姉に帰っ猫はこれっ
これじゃあもうちょっと通ったコンビニ3日カウンター
栗原当時のかけられるんですよねここ
急なんですけどそこつい最近まで開いてたところなんであの本当にあるねやったら違う
ノーミスっで
山道の方が上がってるんですけどそこが本当の旧蔵原トンネルの級の蔵原トンネルで
本当にヤバい所
な通行止めんっあっあっああっもうあの23年前まで通っなんでそんなに大層ないん
ですけど意義がティナーあるんですけどそこをにょちょっと崩落したよなぁ
今を暇ですかまぁ暇ですけど道だけ教えて言うよね
ちょっとつですよね大ずっちゃというわけでみなさん
とんでもないことがわかってしまいます
年か僕たちが以降そしてたこの通行止めだったクラーラトンネルが9
蔵原トンネルでねほんとにやばいところが地元の人から聞くと救急蔵原飛んでるって
場所にあるみたいなんで今からちょっと場所だけ教えてもらってついていこうと思い
ます
we are ヌー正直次の心霊スポット探してたなんて言えないいい
はいここさっき言ったんすよ
最近までこれたところです英智だと思うんですけどね
あああああやばいやばいやばいその像ありがとうございます
お気をつけて俺高2じゃ帰る気を付けねー
サイン会てよかったやっぱファンを大切にしなきゃ駄目ですねやファーは大成しないと
ダメ2たり
戻ってきてしまいました2個とめだってばそのほんと右にほっそい道があったんです
けど
ここから登ると本当にさらに古い99
蔵原トンネルがあるみたいなので行ってみようと思います
はいというわけで福造を転じたんだ
これでいこうと思います
エコぜ
[拍手]
道家が口に入っ
[音楽]
ちょっと中だけできました
まず条約のペースが速いもう
ってもう呪われてますねさてはいや大丈夫よくそんな
いけますね俺結構怖いですよ
[音楽]
えっえっマジですげー無理だよこれ
濃い汗が亡くなられちゃうよ
は確かに静かにしてると熊木沢から逆に騒ぎながら行ったほうがいいすっぽりじゃあ
行きます
うわぁルーフハーフ
[音楽]
催すりこ
あって a
蜜がねぇ
登りじゃなくなった
a
is 2
なってほんとどこ向かってな足がヤバイ
今になってでしたほんとだなぜよく切れるかセローぜ
ましたなぁ
[音楽]
いやあああっ思い出す今入ったステッカー
yeah
結構で a 全部見てください
このこの
ムシキングやっぱってどんだけ欲しいアーマードロワーにねん
待ってほんと危ない邪魔じゃない直球でイタイイタイイタイイタイ定義がある
[音楽]
そんなてゆけためつ開けましたもう行くしかないですねここまで来るぞ
これやああん
見えるがすごいあっございます
メッツ広いとも言った
コンクリートですよで放送されているほんとだ
を買ってみたい上部に対中国人だろ
間違い月末に近いここで動画が旧た瞬間やめよう
はい道路がある時点でまだ可能性はなんかいますけど頑張っ
クロールやまず
goo
4日
ん
持っています
まず大キ本当に声だけで正解とかちょっつーかいっ
いる汗じゃんっ ua 全く泣かないですっ
goo
ん
[音楽]
聞くでねこれ
朝からとっている
イクスカ
君の手で載せていた池さと wiki の日よーっ
空を
話せにの
の手を止めていくよー
さあ
んは前田目を貫きねえ
ガーかあさーんあった
末までにないように本当に強い
まず何
場所で生かそううんうーんああ
うーんわぁ奪ってな塗られ
[拍手]
ほんと声出さなかった聞こえだしは女しちゃいますメッツで踊ってませんですかなぁ
うーん
ああ
犬付いて来たんだね
うわぁ
ねえですかタリムのほかねして良かった水が入ってからほんと願いますじゃないのでは
これだサー
はいはーい
で発生私重いのがいた今
飛んでる9回
[音楽]
car
me
me あった